and I get a lot of letters from kids I
had one recently which said dear David
I'm writing to you because you're my
second favorite awesome my favorite
author is JK Rowling but my teacher said
she's going to be too busy to reply so
I'm working
[Applause]
I think I knew somebody new JK growling
I thought she might amuse her send it to
her and she wrote back and said it said
it reminds me of when I went to school
and did a talk and all the kids were
asked to write on a piece of paper what
they thought of the talk afterwards and
one of the girls just wrote she needs to
brush her hair I think it's something I
put on Twitter dear David Walliams I
love your books but I got one book
wasn't very good book was building there
boy it just wasn't that funny I didn't
really think it was that good but I
loved your other books I gangster granny
and demon Tencent I'm getting more of
your books back to billionaire boy
thank you sincerely Molly it says a
couple nice things but you know let's
get back to me
he's no good
children they are very honest and
they've got letters and told Rumi
collected on various websites and we
just we picked out a few so dear mom
thank you so much being my mom without a
different mom I'd punch her in the face
[Applause]
wouldn't you'd cry you really would but
sometimes when children right there are
difficulties with the spelling for
instance here's one about a nice teacher
they have here we go
this is I like mrs. Edwards she is my
teacher I like when she does mess with
us
[Applause]
sometimes the spelling is so off you not
really sure of the meaning here's
another letter dear Miss Karen I'm sorry
that you feel off your dick
we'll never know what really happened
okay very high dick we think maybe was
it bike with the D in the body fell off
Oh baby I thought she's misspent well
the word feel as well
I feel your dick here's a nice boy from
a girl who's very very impressed to buy
her father's abilities in the kitchen
but sadly she's got a little wrong where
she goes my dad is the best [__] she
hasn't helped things with the picture
she's drawn
[Applause]
[Music]
my trip that leads to you Nina sorry
Nina Nina yes like an ambulance